global leaders gathering at the un
climate change wants more on the agenda
but talk no longer enough this is an
emergency and time is running out boris
johnson wants cash i'll stress that
again that with the need if this is to
be a success for
developed nations to find 100 billion
the pm pushing hard to secure cash ahead
of cop and his efforts receiving an
endorsement from the us do you think
president prime minister johnson is
doing a good job on climate change
yeah i think he's doing a lot britain's
doing a lot they're prepping the meeting
and
fully determined to get it done so
i think we're all moving forward mr
perry how confident are you about
hitting that hundred billion
dollar fund for developing nations boris
johnson said last night on the plane
over he gave it a six out of ten chance
to get it done by cop well i think we're
gonna get it done by cop yeah i think
we're going to get it done by cop sure
thank you so much the united states will
do its part
so you're hoping president biden will
add more funds this week i'm not hoping
i'm
telling you stay tuned to the
president's speech and we'll see where
we are
the pm is one who'll be listening keenly
to president biden's words the united
states is crucially important a game
changer if president biden adds more
funds isn't it will make a huge
difference and i think i think it will
send a massively powerful signal to the
world
the developing countries that i've just
been talking about the we in the in the
industrialized west really do take it
seriously and we really are willing to
step up to the bank
but climate change is complicated and
it's not just about doing more to help
some countries need to do less to harm
the p emerged in his brazilian
counterpart to halt deforestation in the
amazon the battle against climate change
being waged on more than one front
with the g20 group of industrialized
nations pumping out 80 percent of the
world's emissions the prime minister
knows that the uk the us china russia
need to do much more to tackle climate
change
but at this crucial summit at the un
there was good news today with the
prospect of more hard cash to help more
countries go green the prime minister
got an unexpected
bonus too with the us announcing that
from november double-jabbed brits can
come here to visit
two goals then that he down played now
landing but still so much more to do
before cop
the pm wants game-changing action at the
glasgow summit in november a moment he
says history will judge the us and uk
aligned the question is can they bring
the rest beth rigby sky news new york